on a tous envie de faire quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas encore osé démarrer je
vais vous donner un truc que j'ai
découvert grâce à la course à pied et
qui m'a permis de faire tellement de
choses que je n'aurais jamais osé faire
avant je me suis mise à la course à pied
complètement par hasard un matin à la
sortie de l'école madame sarfati la
directrice s'avance vers moi avec un
grand sourire et à son sourire je sais
qu'elle va me demander quelque chose
madame buisson l'association sportive de
l'école organise la semaine prochaine
le cross des parents trois kilomètres
dans le bois de vincennes c'est une
petite course sans prétention
l'essentiel vous le savez bien c'est de
participer merci
et puis nos enfants sont tellement
contents
une fois qu'elle a dit ça comment dire
non
j'ai 32 ans je suis plutôt en forme et
le jour j je me présente avec mon vieux
jogging en coton et mon t-shirt tu veux
saluer mes filles et je rejoins l'ère où
sont les autres parents et là tout de
suite je sens que quelque chose ne va
pas
les tenues sont un peu trop technique
les mamans sont très très en forme et
les papas sont en train de s'échauffer
comme des pros et en effet dès le début
de la course je sens que ça ne va pas
c'est pas un petit cross tranquille de
trois kilomètres qui vient de démarrer
c'est un sprint de trois kilomètres qui
vient de démarrer couru par des parents
fous encouragés par leurs enfants
hystérique la réalité me rattrape
brutalement au bout de 500 mètres la
maman avec qui j'ai pris le départ me
lâche et accélère j'ai l'impression que
mes poumons vont exploser et que je fume
depuis 15 ans par fierté je continue de
courir et par fierté seulement et je
fini par franchir enfin à la ligne
d'arrivée dans un état lamentable
sous le regard inquiet de mes deux
filles est inquiet c'est pire que déçu
je courais pour leur faire plaisir je
courais pour qu'elle soit fière de moi
et elle était juste super inquiète de me
voir complètement ruinée après cette
course
le constat est sans appel j'ai 32 ans et
je ne suis pas si en forme que ça et à
l'époque l'idée que je me fais d'une
maman c'est qu'une maman ça doit être
très fort et très solide et je prends ce
jour là ma première leçon de vie grâce à
la course à pied comment est ce que je
peux espérer courir pour mes enfants
si je ne suis pas assez en forme pour
courir
comment je peux espérer être utile à mes
enfants élever mes enfants si je n'ai
pas la force et l'énergie pour le faire
et c'est comme ça que je commence la
course à pied je décide de m'entraîner
et pour me motiver à chausser les
baskets tous les dimanches je prends
rendez vous je retrouve des amis
coureurs ont cours une petite heure et
puis surtout on se parle on se raconte
nos histoires courir me fait du bien je
sors je remets mon corps en mouvement et
curieusement c'est ma tête qui respire
mieux
et puis cette année-là je rencontre
mariage et gérard qui s'entraînent car
ils préparent leur premier marathon
incroyable épreuve de 42 km et ils vont
me demander un service
est ce que tu veux bien nous accompagner
sur un morceau du marathon entre le 21e
et le 31e kilomètre
comme pour le cross de l'école je dis
oui
et dans cette expérience extraordinaire
je vais apprendre deux choses la
première c'est que courir pour quelqu'un
ça peut être incroyablement motivant tu
te dépasse
tu sais pourquoi tu cours je courais
pour les aider à accomplir quelque chose
et d'ailleurs ce jour là c'est pas 10 km
que j'ai couru mais 22 parce que j'ai
pas osé m'arrêter au 31e
quand il était si fatigué physiquement
et moralement
mais quand tu cours pour quelqu'un
le danger c'est de s'oublier parce que
tu t'adaptes à son rythme et que tu ne
cours pas à ton rythme et le rythme de
quelqu'un il est soit plus rapide que le
tien soit plus lent que le tien mais
dans un cas comme dans l'autre
quand tu ne cours pas à ton rythme
pendant trop longtemps tu te fatigues où
tu te décourages où tu te brûle et puis
la deuxième chose que j'ai apprise à
l'occasion de ce marathon c'est avec
gérard on est au 25e 26e kilomètre on
est sur les quais de seine
et puis il ya tous ces gens qui sont là
pour encourager les marathoniens parce
que c'est très difficile
et puis sur le bord jantes en alléger à
alléger
alors je me retourne vers gérard et je
lui dis dont gérard tu as mené plein de
copains c'est vraiment génial tu es venu
avec plein de monde et lamont gérard se
retourne vers moi et sur son tee shirt
je vois écrit deux grosses lettres ggg
rare c'est le premier homme que j'ai
rencontré keith avait demandé de l'aide
gérard demande de l'aide parce qu'il
sait avant de démarrer la course qu'à un
moment donné ça va être compliqué et
c'est aussi ça être coureur un coureur
c'est pas quelqu'un qui aime souffrir un
coureur s'est simplement quelqu'un qui
s'attend à la difficulté est plus la
course est longue
imaginez la longueur d'une vie et plus
tu sais que forcément à un moment donné
ça va être difficile voire même
douloureux voir mes amis courir ça
m'inspire ça me donne envie est assez
rapidement je m'inscris à mes propres
courses chronométrées
je commence par un 10 km et puis le dise
m'entraîne vers 1 15 1 20-1 semi
marathon ensuite la marche est un peu
haute mais un jour je franchis le pas et
je m'inscris pour le marathon de new
york et le 2 novembre 2008
je finis mon premier marathon c'est
juste avant l'élection de barack obama
yes weekend oui je suis capable et cette
confiance me donne envie d'aller plus
loin
me donne envie de continuer
en 2009 je démarre un autre genre de
course
le trail le trail c'est pas simplement
un autre genre de course
le trail c'est carrément un autre monde
tu cours dans la nature sur des
distances plutôt longue avec des
dénivelés positifs et négatifs
autrement dit ça monte et ça descend
c'est très engageant physiquement et
pour pouvoir se nourrir régulièrement le
trailer il court avec son sac sur le dos
ça s'appelle courir en autonomie et ça
aussi ça m'apprend plein de choses
les les milliers les centaines des
milliers de pas que je vais courir avec
mon sac sur le dos sont autant de chocs
répétés sur mon corps est la bonne idée
c'est de courir léger portait juste ce
qui m'appartient portait juste ce qui me
fait du bien
autrement dit ce qui est utile et
précieux pour moi et pour dire les
choses simplement
personne ne peut préparer ce sac à ma
place j'ai appris à me connaître je sais
ce qui me nourrit ce qui me fait du bien
mais porte bonheur makrem magique pour
les pieds la photo de mes enfants bien
sûr en juillet 2009 avec mon sac sur le
dos je démarre un stage avec un groupe
d'ultras trailer quatre jours dans la
montagne et deux heures après le départ
je me dis que c'est de la folie que ça
va pas être possible
et puis mon corps étonnamment s'habitue
à l'effort à la pente
je trouve mon rythme
la montagne est incroyablement belle et
puis il ya les autres qui m'attendent un
peu plus haut et je fini par arriver moi
aussi en eau et nous commençons alors à
descendre et là surprise descendre en
courant c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que de grimper en courant j'ai peur je
me crispais au lieu de me relâcher je
refuse la pente au lieu de l'accepter
mes cuisses me brûle et je pense que je
vais m'arrêter et il ya cette ultra
trailer qui vient se mettre à côté de
moi qui me regardent et qui voit que je
souffre il va me dire cette phrase
magique il me dit delphine à un moment
donné la douleur n'ira pas plus loin
à un moment donné tu n'auras pas plus
mal et ça m'aide
ça m'aide à continuer à rester dans la
course pendant sept ans je vais courir
des centaines de kilomètres de course à
pied et en parallèle dans ma vie
professionnelle et dans ma vie
personnelle dans ma vie privée
c'est compliqué je cours aussi beaucoup
je travaille pour le père de mes enfants
et ça va très vite
ça va trop vite c'est pas mon rythme
j'ai envie d'un troisième enfant mais
ils n'arrivent pas les projets
s'enchaînent les uns derrière les autres
mais je ne comprends pas le sens
nous courons côte à côte mais pas
vraiment ensemble et quand tu cours sans
savoir pourquoi
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué de courir
même si tu as des objectifs tu peux pas
être complètement bien dans ta cour si
elle n'a pas de sens et un jour en
courant mon genou me lâche ça me fait
tellement mal que je suis obligé de
m'arrêter
c'est la première fois que j'abandonne
est abandonnée c'est pas facile pour moi
mais mon corps a compris avant ma tête
avant mon coeur peut-être que cette
course de 15 ans n'est plus la mienne et
qu'il est temps pour moi de changer de
vie
ma famille est épuisé je suis épuisée et
nous divorçons cinq semaines en
divorçant je perds mon travail et j'ai à
la maison
deux adolescentes qui viennent de passer
une année très difficile et qui ont un
besoin urgent que leur maman aille bien
et pour finir je découvre que je suis
enceinte
qu'est ce que je vais faire
alors je fais comme dans la montagne
c'est pas ma tête qui va choisir c'est
mon ventre je me connecte à mes
sensations et là je sais je sais que je
me remettrai de tout de tout mais pas de
ne pas garder cet enfant que j'avais
désirer alors je choisi de le mettre au
monde et je choisi de vivre
et comme pour mes filles je sais que
pour bien courir pour lui et avec lui je
vais avoir besoin de savoir courir pour
moi mais comment je vais faire c'est une
nouvelle vie qui démarre une autre
course ma course personnel et pour
commencer cette course je vais faire
exactement comme pour la course à pied
tout ce que j'ai appris dans la course
je vais m'en servir
et la première chose c'est que je sais
que cette course personne ne peut la
courir pour moi personne ne peut porter
le sac à ma place c'est ma course
et puis je sais aussi que c'est
difficile mais qu'à un moment donné la
douleur elle ira pas plus loin et ça
m'aide à continuer et puis bien sûr
après la naissance de mon fils je
recours pas tout de suite un marathon et
je commence par recourir des 10 km je
vais chercher des petites victoires qui
me font du bien je rencontre d'autres
coureurs et quand ça va moins bien comme
gérard j'ai appris à réclamer de l'aide
j'engage de la même façon toutes mes
courses professionnelles relationnel
amoureuse d'abord je m'inscris ensuite
je m'entraîne
c'est dans la sueur que je dise où mes
peurs pour ouvrir mes horizons je me
pousse à sortir pour aller courir bien
sûr mais aussi pour construire un
nouveau métier
et puis pour aller danser et puis pour
faire l'amour aussi
c'est en courant qu'on apprend à courir
pas en restant sur le bord est en amour
c'est exactement la même chose
il faut sortir et s'entraîner chaque
course que je termine me replace sur une
nouvelle ligne de départ depuis que je
choisis mes courses je suis plus
heureuse et je réussis mieux je cours
une vie qui me ressemble et je deviens
une femme meilleur et aussi une
meilleure maman pour mes enfants parce
que je vais bien et parce que cette
course que je courais qui s'appelle la
vie a de nouveau un sens on a tous
quelque chose qu'on a envie de faire
mais qu'on n'a pas encore osé démarrer
peut-être même que ce rêve
cette petite audace vous l'avez là ce
soir dans la tête alors le truc c'est
d'abord je m'inscris avant d'être prêt
et puis ensuite je le dis c'est ça le
secret partagé à voix haute
dire tout haut ce que vous avez envie de
faire à des gens que vous connaissez et
aussi à des gens que vous ne connaissez
pas je viens de m'inscrire pour le
marathon de paris en 2016
ça fait sept ans que j'en ai pas couru
j'ai un peu peur est-ce que j'en suis
encore capable je ne vous connais pas
mais en vous le 10 ans je m'engage un
peu plus dans ma promesse et puis
surtout je ne suis plus seul et ça fait
du bien
le premier pas c'est toujours de
s'inscrire et de le dire pour ne pas
rester seul avec ses rêves et toutes les
courses commencent par un premier pas
merci
monsieur